here's my question though speaking of
animals your wife posted um a video of
your dog's reaction to a cut out of you
so i want to show everyone that
yeah that's setting the pigs off does
your dog does your dog not like you it
really shows how my family doesn't like
me and
uh yeah that dog well he does apparently
doesn't like me in two dimensions uh
okay it scared him yeah so that cutout
now takes him for a walk each day and
he's fine he's much more used to it but
that's bean bag he's a nut job so he's
our he's we have three dogs i was gonna
say you do love animals though we have a
rabbit that lives in a shower and i'm
not kidding what well all right we had
two rabbits and one of them sadly passed
away and we were worried that it was
that something was going with the cage
so my wife put it in
the shower and the rabbit uh rejuvenated
she's like saint francis it
it was great and now the sh it just
lives in the shower near the kitchen and
so when people come over
and they do their business there's a
bunny in the shower and so many of them
come out and go there's a
rabbit in your shower
and you're like and i'm like you're
kidding and then i run in there
and i was like yo we had two rabbits and
um
they would fight we found what we were
like what's going on i can't put my
female bunnies near each other they
fight we had two rip at each other oh
and we noticed one on their ear like one
of them was gnawing on the ear and then
we took them to the vet and the vet goes
oh it's what i thought yeah one of your
bunnies ate the testicle off of the
other bunny you told me this i feel like
we've had this conversation oh my gosh i
forgot about that yeah i had to separate
mine but mine's trying to get away right
well i mean if another bunny was trying
to remove its genitals then i would
they don't touch each other we have them
separated yeah we didn't know we didn't
get that rule but mine also don't have a
suite and a in a house with a bathtub
well it's super nice uh it's a spa
treatment uh we do the steam bath for
the bunny the bunny's name is junior
joey what's up the pigs the pigs are
fine they're somewhere oh there they are
okay they're now producing their own
there's a lot of people here i'm sure
they're fine guys you want to come back
again no one's listening and that's that
makes me so happy
[Music]